- [Narrator] This is a run on a bank.
This is also a run on a bank.
And while these people lost their money,
these people didn't
thanks to a government
agency designed back then.
- [President Roosevelt] We
do not want and will not have
another epidemic of bank failures.
- [Narrator] The FDIC exists
to ensure your money is safe
and that bank closures
don't rattle the US economy.
Here's how it works and what
happens when your bank fails.
Let's start back with
these people in the middle
of the Great Depression.
They were afraid their banks
would go out of business
and their money would vanish,
so they'd run to withdraw it all first.
But the issue, as President
Franklin Roosevelt
explained at the time, was-
- [President Roosevelt] When
you deposit money in a bank,
the bank does not put the money
into a safe deposit vault.
It invests your money in many
different forms of credit.
- [Narrator] He means
your bank doesn't have
enough cash on hand to pay out
all their accounts at once,
not back then or today.
So during a run, the bank
would have to suspend business
and most would then completely fail.
Thousands of them did,
which just made other people
panic about their money,
so they'd run to their bank.
- And that's how a bank run on one bank
can become contagious to other banks.
- [Narrator] So FDR signed
the Banking Act of 1933,
creating the Federal Deposit
Insurance Corporation,
the FDIC, to make people have faith
their money was safe in a US bank.
It worked.
- [President Roosevelt] Your
government does not intend
that the history of the past
few years shall be repeated.
- [Narrator] The FDIC is what
it sounds like, insurance.
For every $100 you deposit,
your bank has to put a few cents
into the FDIC'S Deposit Insurance Fund.
This is what's used to
reimburse you, the depositor,
should your bank fail, but
only up to a certain amount.
Currently, if you have
$250,000 or less in a bank,
all that money is insured.
Any amount in a bank account
over that is uninsured.
You could in theory lose
it if the bank fails.
This applies not only
to personal accounts,
but also to businesses.
When a bank is on the
brink of failure, the FDIC,
along with a regulatory
agency, gets involved.
Typically, they arrange to sell the bank
to another usually larger bank,
then close the failed bank,
trying to make the process seamless
for the bank's customers.
- Taking the failed bank,
selling it to a healthy bank
will ensure that there's
continuity of services
to the community that the bank serves,
not just protecting insured deposits,
which the FDIC always does,
but usually the buyers would pay enough
to cover the uninsured, too.
They wanted the uninsured 'cause
those were large deposits.
And then also continue
servicing the loans,
keep the credit lines open,
you know, all the services
the bank provides.
- [Narrator] Over the years,
most failed banks have been small.
Here they are skilled by size,
except for this one,
Washington Mutual in 2008,
the largest bank failure in US history.
Most of the accounts,
primarily personal accounts, were insured,
and the bank was sold for enough
money to cover the insured,
no need to even touch the Deposit Fund,
but also cover the uninsured accounts.
But the bank failures of
2023 haven't been routine.
With Silicon Valley Bank, the
vast majority of depositors
had accounts with more than
$250,000, so they're uninsured.
It's a lot of businesses,
and because the bank
began to fail so quickly,
the FDIC hadn't lined up a buyer
before they had to close it.
- Their deposit base was
a very close-knit group
of VCs and their portfolio companies,
and word just spread like fire.
You know, when a couple
of 'em got worried,
they all started to run.
- [Narrator] So the US announced-
- All customers who had
deposits in these banks
can rest assured,
I wanna rest assured they'll be protected.
- [Narrator] Experts say
guaranteeing not just the insured
but also the uninsured
was aimed at stopping any
further economic damage
from these businesses not making payroll,
but also might have stopped
other uninsured account
holders from running.
- If the uninsured depositors in bank A
can't access their funds,
that's going to make the depositors
in bank B nervous.
We have contagion, and
then we're back to 1933.
- [Narrator] Reimbursing
all these depositors
will come from the
eventual sale of the bank
and also from the insurance fund.
Many experts are worried the
amount banks have to contribute
may go up, so your bank fees could, too,
a process that while messy
worked the way it was designed
nearly 100 years ago.
- [President Roosevelt] I
can assure you, my friends,
that it is safer to keep
your money in a reopened bank
than it is to keep it under the mattress.
- I think on the one hand, FDR
would be wincing and saying,
"Oh man, I thought we wouldn't
have screw ups like this.
On the other hand, I think
he would smile and say,
"Ah, it didn't spread.
"We haven't had contagion.
"We haven't had widespread runs.
"That was my goal in creating the FDIC."